on applaudit très fort l'autre gold les
services les premières places on a
toujours plaisir à les accueillir
bonsoir mes amis parlez nous de calicots
barre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au nom des yeux des frères tranquille tu
rêves
[Musique]
tandis que des sirènes aux cheveux d'or
comme un soleil l'eau l'agent ciel
quant à fo
[Musique]
à
c'est l'habitat
[Musique]
tournante à manège
montrer les mots solennels comme un
soleil offrant de l'eau une âge aux
siennes de son vaisseau
[Musique]
m eur
jours
je t'aimerai toujours
[Musique]
matin
vas-y devant toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c
[Musique]
oh
un niveau bas
[Musique]
les coudes
matin
l'idée pantois
[Musique]
m
là
[Musique]
c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça